I am Dan Galpin.
I am the promotion coordinator of Google Android developers.
Now is the Android tool time
We will introduce Android Studio 2.2 here.
We previewed Android Studio 2.2 at the annual web developer conference held by Google this year.
Showcase some new features and improvements
During the preview and test phase
We listened to and tested your feedback.
We are proud to announce that Android Studio 2.2 is now available.
Can be downloaded on a stable channel
Android Studio 2.2 has improvements in every stage of application creation -
Including prototype design interface design
Code development and iteration
Testing and fine tuning
Let me take a look at these improvements with you.
We modified the layout editor
And added built-in support for restricted layouts
Visually by specifying view position and boundaries on Android
Build a new dynamic user interface
Layout Editor adds blueprint mode and property panel
Can be modified using the icon tool above
So you don't have to go back to text mode.
When you need to debug your UI
We have a new layout detector
Allows you to run on a device or emulator
Capture snapshots of hierarchies and attributes
We will continue to improve the code editor
Further update the Lint check
Resulting in better code analysis
When you need to make sure the API is used correctly
When asking for Android sample code
You can also right click
Search all examples on GitHub
We have upgraded to IntelliJ 2016.1
It adds a lot of features
Such as left-to-right language support and method parameter reordering
Because of Firebase integration
You can now easily add Firebase services
Such as analytics data cloud messages and crash reports in the app
Includes initial project setup and adding dependencies
We will provide convenient documentation links and code snippets
You can add it to your app to get Firebase functionality.
And can make it flow smoothly
To better understand what happened during the consolidation of the list
You can use now
Merge list check viewer
This will let you preview the list
Because it will be in different colors
Highlight other manifest files in the library
Provided content
When the developer wants to check what the APK does.
We are in Android Studio
Build a new APK Analyzer
Just open the app's APK
You will be able to check each component
Estimated downloads in the space occupied by the app
Even taking into account the amount of compression that the Google Play Store has on the app.
By comparing features relative to previous versions of the app
You can easily analyze the size regression of the APK
By going deep into classes.dex
And check the contents of the source file
You can also debug MultiDex issues
Anyone who writes native code in the library will be excited
Because we build systems with CMake and NDK
Added support for C and C++ projects
Now you can import the original project in Android Studio accurately.
And use improved technology
Edit and debug C and C++ code in the IDE
For those who work directly with OpenGLES
We joined the beta version of the GPU debugger
It can record GL commands at runtime and allows you to replay in every frame
After each instruction
Thoroughly check the status of GL
Includes buffer textures and grid content
We are still adding some new features to the GPU debugger.
And improve its speed and stability
That's why we call it the beta
In the Bug Tracker in the Android Studio Google+ Community
Advising our new tools
In this new version,
We want developers to try to create new tools for UI testing --
Espresso test recorder
Also a beta
Test recorder in the emulator
Record your interactions with the app
And allows you to add assertions in a simple interface
The generated test is just a simple Java code that uses the Espresso library.
Therefore, if there is a need in the future
You can customize them
Android Studio 2.2 is just right
Update with SDK Tools 25.2.2 and Android Simulator
Also released
The emulator now lets you simulate several Android sensors in the emulator UI
Accelerometer magnetometer
Environmental thermometer, etc.
Includes 3D devices that can be moved
As always, the latest Android Studio
Also made internal improvements to other features
For example, modify the build time for instant run
Support for annotation processors in the Jack compiler,
New app package code
And better accessibility support in the IDE
To make sure you can make the most of this version,
Remember to update your project with the Android Gradle plugin
So that you can use version 2.2.0
Using SDK Manager
Update your build tools and emulator images
Don't forget to enable instant running
I believe you will like Android Studio 2.2.
Many new features and improvements in its stability
As always we expect your feedback